bonjour gilles rémy merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france pour vivre
ensemble cette journée six spéciales en
russie vous avez vécu donc en russie que
représentent ces célébrations du 9 mai
pour les russes pour les c'est très
difficile de 2,2 d'expliquer à un public
français effectivement l'importance de
cette fête puisque c'est une
c'est une fête une fête de joie mais
aussi de dates en émotions puisque à la
différence de la plupart des pays
occidentaux la en russie et ennuyeux en
ex union soviétique chaque famille koné
a connaît un grand père grand-oncle à un
ancêtre qui a qui a combattu qui souvent
étaient morts vous rappeliez 27 millions
de 2,7 millions de morts pour cette
victoire et donc c'est un c'est
certainement la fête n'a plus la la plus
puissante de 22.9 et je voulais aussi
que vous votre correspondante l'a dit
très justement c'est ça vaut pour la
russie mais ça vaut pour la plupart des
pays de l'ex union soviétique
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est à moscou mais
c'est aussi hk balle à tachkent à almaty
que les kazakhs les ouzbeks ou les
turkmènes vont fêter aussi ce qui est
des c'était considéré comme la fête de
la victoire et de la défense de la
patrie
même si la patrie commune a disparu
depuis
on sait qu'il ya plusieurs moments clés
1 dans cette journée
du neuf maires se défiler ensuite la
parade de des immortels comme comme on
l'appelle une minute de silence un feu
d'artifice quels sont les moments les
plus importants de cette journée alors
je crois que c'était alors vous avez
cité la parade des immortels juste un
petit mot c c'est quelque chose en fait
d'assez récent c'est une initiative qui
a peu été pris je croyais à il ya il ya
5 6 ans au départ par des journalistes
je crois que c'était en province
et puis très spontanément c'est devenu
quelque chose une tradition c'est à dire
des milliers des centaines de milliers
de russes de familles défilent dans les
rues dans les rues de moscou mais dans
les rues du pays avec la photo d'un
proche qui a participé à la halle à la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est un moment très fort autant la de
la parade militaire que nous allons voir
est extrêmement puissante autant ce
défilé qui ensuite pour me ce qu'on
passe par la place rouge m'envahit
n'aura pas lieu je crois c'est à cette
année pour des raisons sanitaires
ce défilé rassemble toutes les
générations et c'est quelque chose
encore que nous avons du mal à imaginer
nous en tant que française les pauvres
cérémonie du 8 mai hier l'absence de
drapeaux dans paris et donc il ya
vraiment un écart une différence de
perception considérable entre nos deux
pays
est-ce que vous dans votre dans votre
vie dans votre carrière qui vous a mené
en russie est ce que vous avez déjà
assister à ces cérémonies du neuf mais
quels sont les souvenirs que vous gardez
oui bien sûr je j'ai participé à de
nombreux jeux de nombreuses cérémonies
d'une hausse mais je suis rentré de
moscou il y a il y à moins d'une semaine
tout simplement parce que quand
la période est une période de congés et
comme je partage ma vie entre entre
paris et moscou étaient plus efficaces
d'être un être à paris cette semaine et
je regrette quand je vois vos images
justement j'habite à quelques dizaines
de mètres la rue thiers sky à je
regrette de ne pas être à moscou
aujourd'hui pour participer à cette fête
aussi importante
voilà j'en étais tu avais déficit par
d'autres d'une partie puisque encore la
semaine dernière
il ya plus d'une dizaine de lure la rue
de gers sky a été plusieurs fois le soir
le bloquée puisque les véhicules que
vous voyez était en répétition dans la
rue de ce qu'est ce qui montre aussi
l'importance de la préparation de ce de
ce défilé oui vous faites bien de le
rappeler doha dès l'article le disais
tout à l'heure près de trois jours de
répétition pour pour ce défilé militaire
vouliez en tout à l'heure vous êtes un
ami de la rue si vous avez même été
décoré de l'ordre de l'amitié par un
vladimir poutine lui-même il ya quatre
ans quels sont les liens aujourd'hui et
les liens forts qui unissent la france
et la russie
alors les liens les liens qui sont des
liens historiques c'est effectivement et
d'avoir partagé de grands moments cessé
de nous qu une culture française qui a
autant imprégné la la culture russe ça a
été aussi de grands moments dans la
coopération entre les deux pays
enfin l'alliance franco-russe sous la
troisième république mais ensuite le
rapprochement et qu'avait pu faire le
général de gaulle
mais aujourd'hui on vit une alerte
certainement une des périodes les plus
difficiles de la relation de la relation
traque aux russes enfin je dirais pas
cela montre encore mais avec l'europe
avec les états unis et en aurait il ya
une dizaine d'années on aurait
difficilement imaginer qu'on arrive à
une telle situation à une dégradation de
la relation
merci beaucoup gilles rémy d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france pour
commenter un ensemble cette cérémonie du
9 mai je rappelle que vous
être chef d'entreprise merci beaucoup
bonne journée